hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing the morphe
saga and we are continuing our 1858
simultaneous exhibition uh where morphe
faced eight opponents
simultaneously obviously uh in the uh in
birmingham after the
the great tournament so here morphy's
opponent is james freeman and i couldn't
find
a single reference to this gentleman uh
most of these players are not the
absolute top players like we already
mentioned in the previous videos but
they are people of great importance but
i could not find a single reference to
james freeman i searched everything i
searched on
chess history all the darkest corners on
the internet but i wasn't able to do so
so
there's a lot more of you guys if you
find any reference on james freeman
do share and i will also then re-share
that so
thank you for that now getting back to
this game uh it's quite a beauty
a lot of people say about this game not
a lot as i don't think a lot of people
even
have seen this game but that it's uh
sort of an sort of
not an unpublished but maybe a a
forgotten gem
uh in the collection of paul morphy's
game so uh really a wild one
uh let's check it out hope you guys
enjoy it uh morphe with the white pieces
opens
with e4 and for those of you sorry about
that for those of you who are maybe new
to
chess and the channel in general uh when
a blindfold
exhibition is held uh the player holding
the bl the simultaneous exhibition will
usually have the white pieces on all of
the boards this is not an
absolute rule but it is uh something
that
that mostly happens so here e4 by morphe
we have
e5 uh bishop to c4 going for the
bishop's opening
bishop to c5 and now b4
this is not the evans gambit as the
knights have not yet been
been developed but this is the mcdonald
gambit uh coined by
uh alexander mcdonnell the most famous
irish
irish player and uh interestingly even
today uh ireland only has one grand
master who actually
is from russia alexander baburin but
i don't know why but not not really a
popular game in ireland
it would seem uh so maybe that also will
change in the future
uh so the bishop is under attack he
denies
morphe the pleasure of the accepted
gambit so he goes back bishop to b6 and
now
knight to f3 morphy goes after the pawn
and
d6 and interestingly this position has
never been
reached again we have d4 morphe strikes
in the center
we have e captures knight captures and
now knight to f6 now going after morphy
spawn
and morphy knight to c3 defends it and
now
while black could uh well uh continue
the game in a few different ways black
decides to castle first and it is a
perfectly fine move
morphe castles as well and now comes uh
knight
captures on e4 this is not a peace
sacrifice black will win back the piece
but maybe
maybe better was just continuing
development rookie knight bd7
and so on but okay this is where the
where the fun starts with knight
captures on e4
knight capture sunny for morphy grabs
the knight and now of course d5 is
coming with an attack on both pieces so
d5
uh uh freeman wants to win back his
piece
and now bishop the g5 first attacking
morphy's queen and now you should just
play queen to d7
and then morphy moves one of the pieces
he has to give one back and the game
continues
however freeman decided to fully
challenge morphy and he played
queen to e8 now saying that okay
your two pieces are under attack if you
go after the pawn here then i'm gonna
play c6 push back your bishop and then
i'm gonna win the knight on e4
morphy says okay feel free to do that
bishop captures on d5
c6 attacking morphy's bishop but now
morphy just uh uh brings more pieces
into the game rook the e1
already with a deadly threat now if the
d5 bishop is captured
knight f6 check will just win the queen
so this is now a nice discovery a double
attack on the queen
captures captures and after capture is
just bishop captures and this is just
game queen can come to h5 check for
example
deliver checkmate the knight discovering
this square so you cannot play bishop f5
uh this is game over so after rook to e1
we have queen to d7
here uh freeman uh uh says all right
maybe the queen was a better
uh placed on d7 so i'm going to play
queen to d7 now
and now okay the bishop is still under
attack if you move the bishop then the
knight is attacked twice
freeman is winning back the piece either
way but morphy says
not so fast morphy plays knight to f6
with
check now with the royal fork and
the knight has to be accepted if you
don't accept
white doesn't just capture the queen
white goes for checkmate right away and
there's no defense against this queen h7
is checkmate
and if you capture the knight it then
just bishop captures and queen to g5
will be checkmate
so after knight to f6 check morphy's
knight must be accepted
so g captures on f6 and now bishop
captures on f6 again with some nasty
ideas of rookie 3 rook g3
check and this game over black has no
moves here
so here uh queen to d6 uh just going
after that bishop on f6 right
away and now uh what do you play here
the bishop is still under attack
uh the this bishop is under attack so
morphy needs to play something and
morphy plays
another brilliancy here he goes knight
to e6
uh just uh uh the idea behind knight e6
is that he wants to block the g4 square
now queen to g4 is a terrible threat
because queen to g4 will be checkmate
the king has no squares to go to so you
have to capture the knight
and you have to capture it well rather
you should capture it with the bishop
otherwise you're just dead lost
another uh another option instead of
blocking with the knight is also
blocking with the bishop and maybe even
stronger because now
there are clear checkmating patterns
here for example bishop captures queen
to d2 with the idea of queen g5
uh checkmate and now after bishop to f5
preparing bishop to g6 to help out with
the defense
it's still just checkmate queen g5 check
bishop to g6 and now
knight to f5 is deadly there's no
defense against knight stage six
checkmate
but okay uh when discussing these games
we have to remember morphy played
blindfold
uh against eight uh opponents
simultaneously so of course uh
he will not always find it the quickest
way but he will always find a way so
here knight to e6 works just as fine
we have bishop captures you have to
capture guard that g4 square
and now queen to h5 again threatening
queen g5 checkmate
and here was the only moment in the game
where black
actually had uh uh the possibility of a
defense
uh so feel free to pause the video here
and try to find uh
a reasonable defense for james freeman
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on
going for the immediate queen to f4 also
for those who
just want to enjoy the show however
freeman went bishop captures an f2 first
and this is a bit different because
after queen to f4 you prevent queen g5
check and now the problem is uh after
rook captures an e6 it doesn't seem like
you have a good move for white because
if you
capture then just captures with czech
rogue blocks and this is checkmate
uh however after queen to f4 and this
rook captures an e6 that's always in the
position
uh there is the very sneaky knight to d7
now attacking the bishop on f6
twice the rook is under attack the
bishop is under attack and black is even
better here
point is that after you move the bishop
uh you we're just going to capture the
bishop on d5 and the rook is still under
attack
rook moves you have to guard the f2
square rook 8 to e8 and
black is perfectly fine black is black
is even winning here
so this was in the position however
bishop captures an f2 check was played
first and it seems like it's the same
idea the queen is coming to f4 but it's
not
it has one very big difference uh of
course that morphe has to decline the
bishop if the bishop is accepted
then queen captures on d5 and after
queen h6 threatening checkmate
there's the very very unpleasant queen
to f5 check
king ju1 and now queen to g6 defending
checkmate and forcing now a queen trade
so instead after this bishop captures an
f2 morphy played king to h1
but now his king on h1 is much safer and
this is a big problem for mr james
freeman
because now queen f4 he of course finds
this and other than this slight
inaccuracy there really
uh wasn't uh wasn't a moment where
black played poorly i mean for those
days
so james freeman is actually a very very
strong player so morphe continues with
rook captures on e6
as he would in the line that we've
already shown and now of course you
cannot capture because this just results
in checkmate so knight beat the d7 again
uh all of morphy's pieces here are under
attack or on pre
as we say in chess so bishop back to b2
and
now comes bishop to d4 now you see it's
a bit different because in that line the
bishop was on b6 the queen was attacking
f2
and the threat was the queen can capture
with check however here the king is
safely tucked in on h1 and you have to
defend
so what do you play here bishop to d4 is
what was played here
capturing the rook is definitely better
but it's uh
it's a very unpleasant move to play for
example captures captures and
rook to f7 and this holds it's very
unpleasant but
it does hold however after this bishop
to b2 uh we have bishop to d4 he wants
to eliminate morphy's dark square bishop
right away to
nullify any any mating patterns but this
is a big
problem uh because now morphy has few
ways to
uh to punish black uh so feel free to
pause the video and try to find either
of the two ideas while i give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on
finding either of the two ideas and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it's either
rook to e4 followed by rook to g4 check
of course
or just uh you know winning the bishop
here on d4
or g3 and this is what was played in the
game
by playing g3 morphe deprives the black
queen of all of the important squares to
guard against
checkmate so you don't really have a
good square for the queen here if you
try something like queen to f2 just
moving the queen queen g4 check and now
the bishop is lost not only is the
bishop loss but also
uh it's just game just bishop captures
and the queen is lost as well so
instead after g3 we have knight to f6
this is the
uh this is the proper way to defend the
the queen is now also under attack but
now
morphy just trades g captures on f4
knight captures on h5
and bishop captures on d4 we have knight
captures on f4 not c
captures on d5 this is uh uh this is not
good because of rook g1 and
there's just too many problems here
you're getting checkmated in knight g7
rogue captures with
czech king here and now rook to h8 will
be
will be checkmate so there's nothing to
be done here so after bishop to d4 we
have knight captures on f4
and now only now rook to g1 with check
knight the g6 blocking and now it seems
okay i'm gonna grab at least a little
bit more material
but morphy says no problem rook captures
on g6
or rather rook e captures on g6 now this
pawn cannot capture it's pinned
only the h-pawn can capture but now rook
captures and g6 with
check king the h7 and the rook g7 check
uh we have king to h6 if you go to h8
you are getting checkmated right away we
can even show that
captures with check a discovery from the
bishop king has to attack the rook now
again rook g7 check forces the king into
the corner now we capture here and the
king has
no more squares available you have to
block with the rook and then just bishop
captures his checkmate
so after block g7 with check king to h6
was played but now bishop to e4 and now
it's two bishops
and the rook against two rooks with the
black king having a terrible terrible
position there on h6 and it's going to
be impossible to defend this with f5
advancing the past pawn blocking the
light square bishop bishop to d3
and now b6 uh we have rook to g3
and now rook to f7 we have bishop to e5
going after the king here
and rook to e8 freeman brings the other
rook into the game
but it is much too late for such things
so bishop to be for check
king to h7 and rook to g5 now just
going after some more material and also
uh
black has no moves here you don't have
rook d2 you don't have any counter play
along the
the back rank there there's just nothing
to be done here so rookie one check was
played
but morphe just played king to g2 and
now rook to g7 he offers a a trade of
rogues but now bishop captures an f5 the
f pawn was lost either way
so this comes with czech king h8 and now
even h4
and black again without them a few more
moves were played rook captures on g5
bishop captures and now the rook is
useless here on the second rank this
pawn is still defended so nothing
uh nothing cool happening there you you
can even blunder the rook if rookie five
just bishop delivers check picks up
picks up the rook so here rook back to
e8 was played but now king to f3 and
morphy said i'm just gonna
you know march my king up the board uh
you know position my bishop
beautifully here and push the h pawn to
victory and
so it was in this position on move 37
that james freeman who we know nothing
about
resigned the game and another excellent
victory for paul morphy in this
eight-man simultaneous exhibition uh
showing
uh so yeah here you resign uh because
it's a very very straightforward
for example rook of fate attacked the
bishop king defense and
the the black king can just you know do
whatever h5 is coming whatever black
plays doesn't really matter you're going
to play captures captures
uh h6 is coming and that's it uh
whatever
king h8 bishop to d2 now going for this
diagonal you want to have a
perfect setup for for pushing the h pawn
and after whatever you're just gonna
play bishop
check here and now you can just play
this uh and now it's just
game over so of course uh mr james
freeman uh
no that knows this and of course it was
in this position that he resigned
uh so yeah another brilliant victory by
paul charles morphy in this
1848 uh simultaneous exhibition that
took place in birmingham
hope you guys enjoyed it as it really is
uh three pieces i'm pretty always uh
you know a joy to see something like
this and uh
yeah i don't know i i actually don't
remember seeing this game so i imagine
a lot of you are seeing it for the first
time as well so i hope you enjoyed that
uh so i also wanted to mention uh the
the good people at chesable created the
course uh
regarding my video on how to counter the
london system so if you want to check
that out it will be the first
link in the description below it's
completely free so you can check out uh
some of the lines uh pretty much all of
the lines that i mentioned in the video
and they also include a way to counter
uh levy's counter uh
to my london system uh you know
uh counter uh so so you can enjoy that
as well and practice some of those lines
like i said
it's completely free so if you're
interested in that do check it out first
link in the description below
uh but yeah uh that's it hope you guys
enjoyed it i would like to thank nina
victoria vanessa nicolaus
mike wagner uh farmers engelhardt
antonio butch and alan mcbroom for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate
it as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
uh thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day